[Musique]
ils n'ont pas encore 18 ans mais ils
vont voter ou plutôt faire semblant de
voter près de 2000 élèves de l'école
secondaire saint luc ont participé à la
simulation électorales soutenue par
l'organisme civique ce dans 9500 écoles
à travers le canada
comment tu t'es informé j'ai fait des
recherches dans des sites fiables
moi j'ai voté pour le parti vert leurs
promesses pour l'environnement pour les
changements climatiques en fait ces
élèves de 12 et 13 ans n'avait jamais
suivi de campagne électorale avant j'ai
voté pour le parti libéral npd
pourquoi
parce que
j'aimais ce qu'ils ont dit au débat des
chefs
le libéral parce que je trouve que
j'aime que ce soit pour la liberté et
l'égalité des hommes et les femmes j'ai
vraiment ressenti une forte y aller voir
débattre essayer de trouver un consensus
pour savoir c'est des vrais arguments
j'aimerais bien qu'un président à john a
vécu quatre ans avec eux et je pense que
mais même si les dernières fois justin
trudeau a pas gardé ses premiers je
pense que cette fois-ci tout ce qui est
la première à le faire
héritage et a proposé l'idée à ses
collègues mais ne s'attendait pas à ce
que tout le monde embarque dans les
années 2002-2003 les ailes et les votes
les adultes étaient on l'est le hante
les 50 et 60% est là on s'est rendu
compte que c'est avec québec en truck
series québec s'est rendu compte que
cela peut-être préparer la relève
cette initiative moins connus au québec
a attiré un nombre record de
participants cette année on a mis le 54
écoles des inscrits au québec aux quatre
coins du québec donc on est très fier on
a plus que doublé nos chiffres par
rapport à 2015 aux dernières élections
fédérales
les résultats en pourcentage des élèves
avaient été assez similaires à ceux des
électeurs pourtant justin trudeau
pouvoir ce que les jeunes faute peau
statégique justice pour moi je vais
voter pour lui pour que lui perdre où
ils vont vraiment comme eux le centre
les élèves semblent un peu plus à gauche
que leurs parents là on est dans une
école multiethnique et ça le turban lui
ont pas peur de ça alors il est
populaire aussi jack need to d'élèves
ont voté pour le parti libéral
parce que en ce moment c'est pas mal
serré conservateur et libéral mais à
l'ecosse pas très populaire conservateur
énorme erreur c'est le npd les résultats
du vote étudiant seront connus lundi
alors que le bureau de scrutin des
élèves de l'école saint-luc accueillir à
de vrais électeurs ici anne louise
despatie radio canada montréal